[Música]
cuántas veces hemos infravalorado
incluso menospreciado a personas con
discapacidad auditiva porque pensábamos
soberbios y arrogantes que no nos pueden
entender que no son capaces de alcanzar
conceptos que nosotros si me atrevo a
decir que la mayoría de los aquí
presentes lo ha pensado alguna vez os
sorprenderá saber que somos nosotros los
que no llegamos hasta donde ellos son
capaces de llegar
tomemos para ello el concepto tiempo las
lenguas orales presentan el concepto
tiempo dentro de la línea horizontal que
puede ir desde atrás hacia adelante y de
izquierda a derecha así podemos decir la
década de los 60 nos queda muy atrás o
tenemos una semana por delante y también
podemos decir primero hacemos esto y
luego hacemos lo otro igualmente en la
lengua de signos podemos decir hace
mucho tiempo o en un futuro lejano y
también podemos decir lo hicimos antes o
lo hicimos después
pero la lengua de signos también
presenta el concepto tiempo dentro de la
línea vertical y así podemos decir a lo
largo de nuestra vida la segunda o
tercera semana del mes siguiendo esta
misma línea vertical en la que podemos
alcanzar el infinito sin necesidad de
desplazamiento pongamos un ejemplo
matemático para verlo con claridad si
queremos definir la pendiente de un
tramo de carretera
lo haremos dividiendo la altura que se
asciende por ejemplo 15 metros por la
distancia recorrida horizontalmente por
ejemplo 100 metros por lo que el valor
sería 0,15 ahora bien si elevamos esta
pendiente al máximo que sería la
vertical
independientemente de altura que suba un
alpinista por una pared vertical la
distancia recorrida horizontalmente 0 al
dividir la altura por 0 el resultado es
infinito en este caso el infinito es
real es alcanzable y repito sin
necesidad de desplazamiento horizontal
como entendía el filósofo gaston
bachelard que fue quien me descubrió el
concepto vertical de tiempo
las personas sordas conciben en su
lengua un tiempo vertical recordad a lo
largo de nuestra vida del que carecen
las lenguas orales estas personas a las
que probablemente hemos menospreciado
por su discapacidad auditiva pueden
pensar y pensar de manera diferente y
más amplia que las personas oyentes una
de las personas que más me ha marcado en
mi vida ha sido mi profesor daniel virus
gonzález docente extraordinario del que
yo me nutrido para hacer hoy quién quién
soy queréis saber un detalle
daniel es sordo sordo profundo y a
través de él pude comprobar que la única
discapacidad está en la mente de quienes
piensan que ser diferente es ser menos y
también pude comprobar que ser diferente
es un efecto secundario de ser increíble
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]